for our cover this week cover story we
uh we had senior writer devin leonard
look at what's happening at kellogg and
kellogg of course is like the cereal we
all grow up on uh but uh they're
struggling now they've sort of lost
breakfast we were saying
and we wanted to know is that because of
the way they're managing the company and
their finances or is it because consumer
behavior is changing and what people are
having for breakfast is is different
yeah i mean i think uh you know for me
in a story you kind of find out that
it's a variety of things you know one of
them is is consumer tastes one of them
is like you know parents apprehension
about buying foods that don't have the
gmo free stamp on them and so we kind of
toyed around with you know that's kind
of idea where like tony the tiger was
just like looking at a bullet cereal and
like kind of appalled by it in a way it
was no longer the thing that he wanted
right so badly to eat this morning yeah
so let's look at some of the things that
we uh that we mocked up so we thought of
like all the various kellogg's mascots
but we thought tony the tiger was
definitely the one who you know people
might recognize the most you know i
approached this um illustration company
called big shot toy works um who worked
with us in the past and that's some sort
of like you know explore tony you know
above a bowl of frosted flakes looking
nauseous like he's kind of about to
vomit or like he's sad
and uh you know they came up with this
um
version of him just wearing a gas mask
and uh you know
the frost plates look a bit radioactive
we kind of liked it you know the only
tweak was to make him look a little more
appalled by it so you know there was a
second version where he's sort of
raising his hands up a bit more
and then after that we just came had to
come up with a headline tony's signature
catchphrase is there great and so we
just did a little take on that that
you know kind of lent itself to the
concept
it's pretty sweet yeah
you